FRANK: Oh yeah.
OK.
This might be muddy because
the top on this one's open.
FRANK: Oh, we don't
care about mud.
So there you go, fellas.
FRANK: So I get in the second
bunker, here's a Texaco sign.
Here are some cans.
Here's a Coca-Cola sign.
Every room is packed.
It's like putting a fat
kid in a candy store.
"Texaco Gasoline, Localized
For You," I like that.
I think if you look
on the back, it's got--
yeah, there's your name.
It says Frank right on it.
FRANK: It says Frank
right on the back?
That's right.
And you know what it says
right on the front here?
- Uh-huh?
- It says $60.
Ooh.
Yeah, that's right.
You got it.
Hey, Dan, Rob.
The only time I ever
see these signs they're
on top of the buildings.
- Yep.
This was a 17-foot long
sign that went on the top
ridge of the transfer station.
It said Conoco
Oil Company on it.
Very, very highly sought after
sign to the Conoco collectors.
Yeah, they were on
top of the building.
You still have the original
mounts on this one.
Would you do 800 on the pair?
I think it's a
pretty cool piece.
Robbie, I'd like to
have 1,000 bucks.
Can you do that?
- I'll do 1,000.
- Oh.
- Seriously.
- Thank you.
I'll do 1,000 on it.
Appreciate it.
What about the Coca-Cola sign?
It's so bad that it's good.
It's hurting.
It's got rust.
It's got bullet holes.
It's beyond character.
And it's cool.
I would take 150 bucks for it.
All right.
It would be a great piece for
somebody to put on their barn.
No one's going to touch it.
This one's safe and sound.
I think he's got a vision.
You could take a brand
new car and knock a hubcap
and break a headlight
out, and the value
drops to half to people.
They can't see past it.
He can see past it.
- You bet.
- Wow.
- Whoa!
You can pick till you puke.
Frank was digging in a box.
And I said, what
the hell's he doing?
Oh, looky there.
It's a Goodyear's Tire.
You found a nugget.
It's double-sided.
It's still very,
very presentable.
I buy anything
that's good Goodyear,
Goodrich, anything that's good.
$80.
Well, I'm not going
to argue with you.
You found it.
- Team me, baby.
You know, we dug two good things
out of there, any one of them.
Matchless Auto Lamps.
That's bad it's so faded.
FRANK: Look at the girl on it.
Oh man.
- 10 bucks.
- Yeah.
Well, I'll tell you one thing.
He's got a nose for good crap.
FRANK: 50 bucks.
- Absolutely.
All right.
I mean, the guy's
like a bloodhound.
He just went right to it.
S&H Green Stamps--
now this isn't
porcelain, 40 bucks.
Yeah, that's fine.
Frank goes right to
the bottom of the pile
like a rabbit-- you know,
dog hunting a rabbit.
I mean, how do you do that?
150.
I would gladly take that
for it, to be honest with you.
I mean, them guys are
professional pickers.
That's all there is to it.
Heck, I'm doing pretty
good in the front rounds.
Yeah, you are.
You're a scrounger.
This thing right here is
a wind charger for a farm
basically is what they are.
It sat on a pole.
It generated electricity.
Like this one says 32
volt, Wincharger Corp,
Sioux City, Iowa.
This wind generator would have
been used to charge batteries,
to power a radio on the farm.
So this piece is the long piece.
And then there's your
generator up there,
which looks like it's all gone.
The brake is here, but
it's bent and mangled.
Now, I know they reproduce
a lot of these parts.
They're pretty darn cool
when they're set up.
Think about how isolated a
family farm was in the 1920s.
This was their connection
to the outside world.
I'll tell you what
I'd want to do--
this piece and the
tail, the rest of it the
remains here, 400 bucks.
Ooh, that's a lot.
Are you sure you want
to pay that much?
This is a good
decorator piece.
Right, right, right.
OK?
This piece put back together
is going to demand good money.
You get down the road 100
miles, you're going to say,
oh, man, I paid too much.
- I don't think so.
I think 400 is a good number.
OK, buddy.